by this
[Music]
welcome to another exciting episode of
kos
and today i'm going to bring you a
character
that is often all overlooked uh
highly disrespected uh when it comes to
the rogue gallery
of spider-man
and not thought of
as a formidable foe today
today i bring you xm
studios craven
the hunter sergey
kraven off
that name should
send shivers up your spine if you're a
spider-man fan
i think he made his debut in spider-man
uh
amazing spider-man number 15
but he has been a thorn in spider-man's
side
for countless books throughout the years
and i think it was a lack of direction
for the
character because you know you had the
scorpion and you had the rhino and you
had these other characters that were
so robust and so strong
that um craven
was just some guy in tights a hunter
and i i'm so happy that they didn't go
with the tights
and this statue i'm so happy
but there's one
book in particular and i know you guys
know i'm going to bring up
amazing spider-man craven's last hunt
i thought this book
depicted craven
justfully
this retelling of this story
and it is the ultimate tale of revenge
because you know craven was always
overlooked and he couldn't for the life
of him
understand why
spider-man
defeated him so much so the book starts
off you know with craven
reminiscing about his family and it has
a tone
the tone in this book is very
ominous very very forboden very
morbid if you will
and craven doesn't want to go the way of
his family so because he's looking at
his mortality
now to me i believe that there's an
underlying disease
that craven has that
he is forced to face his mortality
in this book and then you know it
switches off to spider-man and he goes
to someone's funeral
and it's a funeral of a uh a low-level
snitch
and they're having it in a bar you know
spider-man comes in and the guys want to
attack spider-man but spider-man you
know
jumps back means like yo i'm just here
to drop off some cash so you can give
your boy a a decent burial
spider-man is not flush with cash you
know spider-man is not tony stark
spider-man is not
a batman so he doesn't have a ton of
money so whatever money he does get
that he does earn his you know his
heartfelt and he felt that he
that this guy deserved
uh great uh burial
[Music]
so saw that spider-man reflexes right
so you know and he put up the cash for
it
throughout this whole tone craven is
gearing up
to fight spider-man he has
spider-man's uh black costume and this
is not the symbiote costume
because at this point in time spider-man
has uh separated himself from venom
and but he likes the black costume
so you know he has a black costume
craven does
and you know this night
he sets out to hunt spider-man
and you know at this point in time
spider-man is married to mary jane and
you know she she's thinking about like
what if he
dies one night while he's out being
spider-man
you know and spider-man has these same
thoughts of mortality
at this point in time craven strikes
uh and you know he actually captures uh
spider-man
you know shoot some some sleek darts or
whatever adam
and then get them in the net and as he
has something in the net
he pulls out a rifle and spider-man is
like yo yo yo
this is this this is not what you do yo
put that away
and blam he blasted him
and you know he's having a funeral he's
at
his uh grounds where his people are
burying spider-man
and he bury spider-man and he dawns
spider-man's costume
and he goes through the city and he's
trying to be spiderman
but he's too brutal and mary jane
happens to come across him in the
spiderman
suit while he's being brutal
beating up and breaking
uh robbers spider-man doesn't do that
spider-man has a form of humanity inside
of him
so you know craven
goes on and
at this time spider-man is still buried
underground he's alive
he's not dead craven didn't kill him
just wanted to conquer him and
he lets out this uh this
uh sinister mr sinister
made this creature called vermin uh
like you know gene spliced them or
whatever
and you know spider-man never defeated
venom uh
vermin he did it with the help of
captain america
so craving a hunter knows this and he
wants to set out and show
the world that he can do it as
spider-man
he brutally beats up vermin and captures
him
and spider-man at this point in time
is underground he breaks out from
underground
mary jane is going crazy spider-man goes
through
the newspapers and stuff like that to
see what was going on
and he's been underground for two weeks
claustrophobic buried alive
conquered by craving the hunter
for two weeks two weeks
craving a hunt has been running around
wearing a suit spider-man sets out
finds craving and start beating craving
up
craving is giving them no resistance
because craven has done
exactly what craven wanted to do
conquer the spider become the spider
and show that he's a superior spiderman
superior spiderman yeah
that part and
he releases vermin and spider-man starts
to go after vermin
and fight vermin
but spider-man isn't brutal
spider-man is is love you know
spider-man is responsibility
spider-man is caring
spider-man subdues uh
vermin and craven
realizes exactly what's the difference
between him and spider-man
and how he could never
actually possess the man
[Music]
craven goes home
spider-man goes to marry jane
and craven blows his brains out
that's craven's last hunt
there's no sugar coating this story
there is no
getting around
the sheer morbid nature of
this phenomenon story
and that's craven's last hunt
now let's get into the statue but we all
know
with xm studios comes
these beautiful art prints that depict
what we see with the statue
and what we get so
you get a sense of what the artist was
going for
when they decided to
make this statue and it shows
craven a hunter in
all his glory
with his blade
that's a big knife his spare
his gun at his side
his beads as well as his teeth
this majestic lion which is heavy
as hell i am not gonna lie
it's beautifully done craven
looks like a modern version of what he's
supposed to look like
with his boots and you can see the wear
and tear on the boots of dirt on the
boots
it has some mixed media here and there
like the lassos he has here
his uh teeth on his neck his collar
you see the muscles of craving
very strong
the physical peak
he has craven's signature goatee
the mustache with the sash
this is part of my sinister six
spiderman rogues gallery
and i am so pleased to have this statue
this statue is definitely
one of spider-man's best role gallery
uh characters like you can see the
stitching
on the jacket the vest actually
with the mane of the lion with the
lion's face
his signature look
beautiful beautiful statue
well this is the part in the video where
i'm going to tell you to
like follow and subscribe and hit the
joy button
hit that join button you know where that
joint button is
it's right there at the bottom so you
hit the join button and you join the
realm
where we have a ton of stuff in the
background that you can see
you can see a whole bunch of uh of
videos
of us going to pax e3 and also you know
just chilling with the lords and stuff
like that to see what we do in the
background
uh we're going to be doing a lot of
giveaways
a lot of statue giveaways as well i'm
going to be doing a ton of raffles
where the you know if you don't have
sixteen hundred dollars for a statue of
this nature
you can join the raffle and win
and get a statue and start off your
collection
or end off your collection but
be part of the realm also go to lords of
gaming.net
where we have a ton of writers ton of
opinion pieces
the next generation has kicked off
playstation 5 and xbox series x
and s is in full swing
you know these scalpers are crazy
but at the same time the start of the
new generation
is definitely the most fun time so
stick around watch this statue in all
its glory
as i go through the building process so
you can see
how heavy this bad boy is
a very solid piece and a welcome
addition
to my xm spiderman collection see you
next week
when i bring you something even more
mind-boggling from xm
stay collecting
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
by this
[Music]
you